hundreds of arrows split the sky dimming
the sun
they arced and fell dropping like sky
eels upon their prey
amaram soldiers raised shields but not
caledon squads
no shields for them sen screamed and the
arrows slammed into the middle ranks of
amaram's army behind him
[Music]
i want to figure out what exactly makes
up brandon sanderson's style based on
what he has said
himself about his style is that he tries
to make it like
clear glass window to make it seem as
invisible as possible the glass is not
there
to obscure it other types of pros are
described like stained glass windows
this is basically concept of poetry
i try for this it's much more of a
craftsman style
than an artist style of writing so is it
really invisible is it possible to have
a style that's invisible and what
exactly
makes up brandon sanderson's style i
will be dissecting a
short passage from the way of kings this
is the first book in the stormlight
archive series i am looking at
chapter one of part one we're following
a character
a brand new character in the story
called sen who it was experiencing
battle for the first time and falls
under the leadership of a character
known only to us as kaladin storm
blessed sen didn't even know who the
enemy was
a landlord was encroaching on bright
lord amaram's territory the land owned
ultimately by high prince sadius it was
a border skirmish
and sen thought it was another alephi
princedom why were they fighting each
other
perhaps the king would have put a stop
to it but he was on the shattered plane
seeking vengeance for the murder of king
gavilar five years before the enemy had
a lot of archers
sen's panic climbed to a peak as the
first wave of arrows flew into the air
he stumbled again itching to take out
his shield but dalit grabbed his arm and
yanked
him forward hundreds of arrows split the
sky dimming the sun
they arced and fell dropping like sky
eels upon their prey
amaram soldiers raised shields but not
caledon squads
no shields for them send screamed and
the arrows slammed into the middle ranks
of amaram's army behind him sen glanced
over his shoulder still running
the arrows fell behind him soldiers
screamed arrows broke against shields
only a few straggling arrows landed
anywhere near the front ranks
why he yelled at dalit how did you know
they want the arrows to hit where the
men are most crowded the large man
flied where they'll have the greatest
chance of finding a body
so i'm going to be breaking down
sanderson's writing style into
five qualities that really stand out in
his writing that really give it a
personality and a style
everyday language the m-dash sentence
fragments and repetition
gerunds and questions and answers the
first point
brandon sanderson uses everyday language
he's writing on epic proportions yet
he grounds it with everyday modern
regular language when he's trying to
describe an army
and they have a huge amount of archers
he just says the enemy had
a lot of archers right another writer
might
describe it with much more visual detail
he just
had a lot of archers along with the
everyday language is that there are
few similes and metaphors and when they
occur they
are very brief and aren't usually there
to create some kind of flowery picture
for example this simile right here they
arced and fell
dropping like sky eels upon their prey
for us starting the book that
image is not completely helpful because
well we can kind of picture what a sky
eel might look like it is more for world
building than it is for
describing the the arrows we know how
arrows
fall we know how arrows look so what's
the point of going into an elaborate
similar metaphor right there
it's really effective because it puts us
in this strange interesting world and
also the word sky eels
is very evocative on its own so why put
in more work than you necessarily have
to so the second point and this is
something i noticed
occurred quite frequently in brandon's
writing and this kind of goes hand in
hand with the everyday
modern language modern sounding writers
will use the m dash
more frequently so what's the m dash
it's just the end dash but longer
right it's just a hyphen but longer
usually it's used
to replace a comma and to make it more
just visually separated from a sentence
so you have a long
sentence dependent clauses and all this
stuff and you want to
pull out a certain piece of information
or if it's if it's an aside you can use
this too
brandon will use it to add clarity the
m-dash
really just helps organize the
information in a sentence brandon uses
really simple everyday sentence
structure the m-dash helps him do that
for example
a landlord was encroaching on breitlord
amaram's territory
the owned ultimately by high prince
sadius in some ways that's better than
akama because
it really puts significance on the
exposition
high prince edius it's owned ultimately
by high prince edius also it just
looks and feels better because he
already has the ultimately there in
commas
i think that looks a little better and i
think it sounds better too
the next thing a stylistic quirk that
sanderson uses he uses lots of sentence
fragments
along with repetition you'll find this a
lot in
important scenes emotional scenes
instead of going
into wordy descriptions of feelings or
things he'll repeat phrases
or add a sentence fragment i'm not
saying one is more effective than the
other and a lot of people would
criticize sanderson for using this maybe
thinking it's shallow or something i
think that
it can be a really effective thing
especially for the style he's going for
which is
peeled back amaram soldiers raised
shields
but not kaladin's squad no shields for
them sen screamed
and the arrow slammed into the middle
ranks of amaram's army but not caledon
squad
no shields for them helps with the pace
right it helps and it's very colloquial
it's very conversational it helps bring
urgency to the moment and having that
period there just but not
caledon squad added emphasis caledon
squad
no shields for them this is important to
the scene it's important that they don't
have shields it's significant there are
more
obvious examples this is just very early
in the story so it's easier to use
there's a lot of this repetition next
point and this is one that i
love gerunds basically what are they
right gerunds are just the present
participle of verbs
but they're used like nouns so hitting
running
ing words used in a certain way used
like a noun
for example he stumbled again itching to
take out his shield hundreds of arrows
split the sky
dimming the sun they arched and fell
dropping like scales upon their
prey basically this is just also saving
word space which brandon's really good
at doing he's really good at being
really economical with his words on the
page
this also lends a sense of urgency
sounds
like present tense it's it's running but
it's in the past tense and i think he's
he's mentioned this in lectures how
using that gerund like that
and adding it to the end of a sentence
can really add a sense of momentum you
know hundreds of arrows split the sky
they dimmed the sun different than
hundreds of arrows split the sky
dimming the sun feels more present feels
more active
and it just sounds a little smoother
right this is
you know very common thing i just feel
like
it's not very scientific but i do feel
like he uses this
quite often and he'll often jump back
and forth between using a sentence that
will
have that gerund and using one that
won't and the final thing i want to
get to is the constant questioning that
his
point of view characters do a tool for
exposition basically
and it's really effective why were they
fighting each other perhaps the king
would have to put a stop to it but he
was on the shattered planes seeking
vengeance for the murder of king gavilar
five years before
okay we have a character asking a normal
question and then
perhaps right it's connect us to the
prologue
to the book just also giving this
exposition and reminding us
about how much time has passed since the
prologue it's been five years and
not only in in turn internally does
brandon sanderson do this but
of course he does it in the dialogue
when sen asks dalet how did you know
about the arrows and he gives the answer
you know that is
a little more common and probably
typical for exposition brandon's just
very good at using that
intern those internal mechanisms to get
exposition across
so after looking at all these qualities
of his writing
obviously there's a lot you could pick
apart and dissect and try to figure out
but
after looking at these things does
brandon sanderson have a prominent
style yeah you know i i do think that he
has a style
it's a style that doesn't try to stick
out in certain ways
but it does stick out in others right it
sticks out in
its use of sentence fragments of
repetition of certain phrases
italics for particular words for
emphasis so there is a style there but
yeah it doesn't reveal much
beyond what brandon sanderson wants to
reveal
it's very to the point and it's very
economical these are long books
the reason they expand so so much has
more to do with scene construction
than it does with the pros style it's
not invisible i don't think any writer
style is invisible
the question is if it's effective and
good i think that really comes down to
the reader i think
largely it doesn't get in the way of the
story i think the story gets in the way
of the story sometimes
i think that writers can learn a lot
from this style because
sanderson excels at what a lot of
writers
don't which is getting to the point
cleaning up
the pros and getting down to the very
essential stuff yeah what does everybody
think about brandon sanderson's
style is it obnoxious is it noticeable
or does it feel
invisible as you read i'm really curious
to see what everyone thinks
like and subscribe as usual hang out a
while watch some videos
that's all i'm gonna that's it